[música]
[reír]
sólo participan en esta operación.
funcionarios profesionales y contratistas
no hay reclutas y nosotros no
planea hacerlo ahora que escuchamos
en qué hacer una zona de exclusión aérea
territorio en territorio en territorio
Ucrania
hacerlo imposible
en el territorio de Ucrania solo es posible
del territorio de algunos vecinos
estados, pero cualquier movimiento en este
la dirección será considerada por nosotros
como la participación en un conflicto armado
del lado de cuyo territorio
amenazar a nuestro
personal militar, estaremos en el mismo segundo
ser tratados como miembros de las fuerzas armadas
conflictos y cena de todos modos
miembros son ley marcial
introducido en el país de acuerdo con la ley
por decreto del Presidente y debe ser
confirmada por la decisión del Consejo de la Federación en
en caso de agresión externa, incluso
áreas específicas para
no tenemos tal situación
y espero la ruina
[música]
Gloria a Ucrania